Depth first search, or DFS on graphs,
operates under the same
principles as DFS on trees.
Keep in mind that a graph search and
a graph traversal
are roughly the same thing.
In a traversal, you look at
every element, and in a search,
you just stop traversing when you
find the element you are looking for.
Unlike a tree,
there's no root in a graph, so
there's no obvious place to start.
You can begin with any node.
First mark the node
you selected as seen.
A common implementation
of DFS uses a stack.
So we can store the node
we just saw on the stack.
Next, you pick an edge, follow it and
mark that node as seen,
and add it to the stack.
As long as there are more edges and
more unseen nodes,
you keep repeating those steps.
When you do hit a node
that you've seen before,
just go back to the previous node and
try another edge.
If you run out of edges with new nodes,
you pop the current node from the stack
and go back to the one before it,
which is just the next one on the stack.
You continue this approach until you've
popped everything off the stack or
you find the node you were
originally looking for.
There's another common implementation of
DFS that uses recursion and no stack.
As you can imagine, you just repeat
the same process of picking an edge and
marking a node as seen until you
run out of new nodes to explore.
That becomes the base case, and you move
back to the last level of recursion,
which happens to be the previous
node in the search.
In this algorithm, we're explicitly
visiting every edge and vertex once.
Thus, the runtime is
often written as this,
which reads the number of edges
plus the number of vertices.
You might notice that we actually visit
every edge twice, once to explore it and
once traveling back through it.
The runtime is technically two E, but
the approximated version
remains the same.
The number of edges by itself actually
summarizes the runtime pretty well, but
the V is added to account for
the time taken to look up a vertex.
That exact time varies depending on
your choice of data structure, so
be careful to base it on your
implementation when asked.
[BLANK_AUDIO]